California congressman Adam Schiff is
the top ranking Democrat on the House
Intelligence Committee he's expected to
become chairman of that committee when
the new Congress is seated in January
congressman good morning you are in the
center of this House investigation -
what's going on
we heard the White House press secretary
yesterday say of Michael Flynn that his
alleged illegal activities are quote
don't have anything to do with the
president is that true well we don't
know yet until we see with the full
cooperation of Michael Flynn it's clear
that he has been cooperating on three
different matters a criminal
investigation which I presume was the
Turkish matter that came to light
recently but also the transition team
and that is Flynn has said that he
talked with other transition officials
including very senior ones about his
conversations with a Russian ambassador
so that when the Vice President went out
on national television and misled the
country about those conversations
they were senior people who knew this
wasn't true and he could shed light on
that now there's a substantial question
is the president one of those people let
me ask you you because you have broad
powers to investigate and when you
become chairman in the new year who is
the first person you want to call to
testify well I don't know the first
person but I'd certainly like Michael
Cohen to come in very soon he clearly
has a lot to say in the special counsels
pleadings it was clear that he had
information that was of core interest to
the special counsel which means that
will be core interest to us as well as
it goes to that probably that conspiracy
issue so I would put him very much near
the top of the public hearing it might
be we would want to discuss that
internally I think we're gonna probably
handle the witnesses on a case-by-case
basis depending on how it would affect
other parts of the investigation they're
also witnesses who've already testified
before the community in that trend those
transcripts have not been made public
will you be making those public early on
we will we will and it's that's been a
goal for quite some time really the
first step though John is we want to
make sure that this special counsel has
access to those transcripts so the
council can determine who may be lying
to the committee that thinks it's hard
for people when they look at the
totality of all the things we hear about
in the news is to get some sense of
whether we're seeing iceberg or tip of
what's your sense of the entire set of
issues confronting the president and how
much of it we know about you know it's
hard to say probably the best indication
we have of that is how much is Bob
Muller redacting from these court
filings and in some cases it's a great
deal if you look at the Flynn filings
for example I mentioned there are three
investigations that he's helped with one
is completely redacted we have no idea
what that's about it looks because it's
not a criminal case like it's probably a
counterintelligence case now does that
involve other foreign funding that went
into one of the Trump organizations
does it involve this nuclear arrangement
he's trying to reach with the Gulf we
really don't know we also don't know
what Michael Cohen has to say when he's
fully cooperating or what other
witnesses before Bob Miller have had to
say so it's very difficult
I suspect that Muller wouldn't reveal
the most important information early in
the investigation so there may be a lot
left to come go ahead I was just gonna
shift gears and ask you about Facebook
I'm sure you've read the latest
bombshell report that the the company
was sharing users data with other tech
companies without users permission given
that does it look like the company
violated an agreement with the FTC it
may very well I'm not into the weeds on
what that consent decree required there
I think
experts much better than I am on that
point but it certainly looks like the
days of Congress essentially deeming the
high tech industry as off limits of you
know beyond the power to regulate that
these are new growing industries that we
don't want to constrain in terms of
innovation those days are over they're
behemoths now they're well-established
and there are well-established problems
privacy being chief among them well one
of the other problems that's really come
to surface about Facebook and the other
social media companies this week was the
other report that the Russian use of the
platforms was more extensive than we
knew and that the platforms hadn't
really brought to our attention fully as
they should have were cooperated with
each other to show us how they used
cross you know platform techniques to
really amplify the right you're gonna
call this
including a specific effort by the
Russians in order to suppress the
african-american vote exactly and use
Facebook as a tool to do that yes that
was very very troubling and disturbing
criminal justice reform on the table
it's passed in the Senate looks very
well in the house is this a sign of
things to come
can the two sides actually work together
this would be a great sign of things to
come I hope it is a sign of things to
come there's no reason why we can't look
for discreet areas like criminal justice
reform and say okay we're gonna have our
differences on the wall and other things
but let's think about where we can come
together they're creating Jared Kushner
he's getting a lot of credit on both so
I do you agree look I think Kushner the
administration generally deserves credit
for being open and supportive of this
reform therapy a big people in Congress
working on this well before Jared
Kushner or anyone else entered the scene
but nonetheless we need all three House
Senate and White House to work together
on this we should be able to do the same
thing on infrastructure in the new year
the country certainly needs it it's not
a partisan issue so let's use that as
the template we were in the green room
and your aides said that you'd said we
need to get to a place of comedy comedy
I'm happy to say there are a lot of
people in green room and nobody knew
that word but you and your aide so what
do you what does that mean well we
probably have enough comedy coming out
of Congress as it is a tragedy more like
comedy in the sense of getting along
better being more civil to each other
and one of the applicants I'm going to
make on the Intelligence Committee is to
try to get us back to some form of
regular order so that we're more capable
of meeting the challenges that face the
committee let's hope so
absolutely thanks very much congressman